justement eric straumann notre invité
président du conseil départemental du
haut rhin cette maison d'alsace on va
rebondir dessus c'était pas prévu comme
ça mais elle vous appartient à vous et
aux départements du 69 c'est une
copropriété des départements du
haut-rhin et du bas-rhin il faut saluer
l'esprit à l'époque de nos prédécesseurs
qui avaient acheté cette maison pour je
crois 9 millions de francs alors
qu'aujourd'hui elle vaut va lier dixième
fois bien ils en auront probablement dix
fois plus en euros on peut dire ça tout
à fait elle renaît de ses cendres bonne
chose pour l'image de l'alsace n'a
beaucoup réfléchi pendant pendant un an
pour savoir quelle quelle sera l'option
que nous allions prendre
est-ce qu'on allait continuer à la gérer
directement c'était une solution gonnard
assez rapidement écartée parce que c'est
pas le métier du département et donc on
a décidé de ne plus attendre puisque
alors en fait on a cherché à à la placer
sur le marché mobile et pouvoir
simplement ce qu'elles valaient est donc
aujourd'hui on a une idée de prix et
donc on l'a confié en août d'entreprises
alsaciennes
car on est par le président d'alliance
n'est pas prise en date fin c'est donc
qu'ils nous la gère et en plus elle nous
rapporte de l'argent avant lui coûtait
600000 euros par an et maintenant elle
vous rapporte à peu près un million des
départements à leur apporte un million
d'euros par an donc je crois que c'est
une opération gagnant gagnant 1 entre
les différents acteurs
et puis ça reste dans le patrimoine des
alsaciens les alsaciens étaient très
sensibles beaucoup ont reproché que j'ai
simplement eu l'idée un moment de mettre
une à lens on ne danse pas là mais
figaro donc on ne touche pas la maison
d'alsace on ne touche pas l'alsace est
riche trop bas nouvelle année 2010 est
on sait que les budgets des
collectivités sont souvent un petit peu
tendu est ce que aujourd'hui avec cette
nouvelle réforme territoriale est ce que
vous avez vous trouvé vos marques
l'année 2016 était objectivement une
année difficile on a dû trouver une
trentaine de millions d'euros
d'économies
le bateau est aujourd'hui stabilisé je
sais comment manoeuvrer
cette belle maison et on a vraiment des
perspectives on sait bien que l'année
2010 est on aura encore un certain
nombre d'efforts à faire puisque les les
baisses de dotations d'état se
poursuivre on perd encore 18 millions on
a su les anticiper et tout est prêt pour
partir pour à partir de 19
18 on puisse lancer de nouveau de grands
projets avec des marges de manoeuvre
financières des excédents de
fonctionnement qui nous permettront
d'intervenir dans les territoires et
aussi dans les différents services que
nous réalisons comme dans l'est dans les
collèges comme aussi par exemple
c'est un accord que nous allions avec la
région l'ancienne région alsace à
l'époque c'est le déploiement du très
haut débit sur l'ensemble du département
du haut rhin
plus de 95% des foyers à l'horizon
2020-2025 auront la fibre chez eux c'est
très très haut débit grâce à la fibre
dont la fibre chez eux à 2006 les je
crois que c'est une révolution assez
importante que l'arrivée de
l'électricité en 1910 où dès le courant
dans les années 50 puis ça ramène même
du développement le développement ils
connaissent pas s'installer elles ont
répondu allemagne voilà et puis dans la
queue dans la continuation de nos
compétences par exemple les personnes
âgées ça leur permettra de sortir de
leur isolement
très simplement les former un petit peu
sur ces nouvelles technologies mais
c'est un enjeu considérable
autre enjeu avec les élus des
départements vous allez lancer une vaste
consultation sur le retour de l'alsace
on va dire à l'alsace air que j'imagine
que vous espérez que des idées nouvelles
jaillissent pour faire revenir l'alsace
la sortir du grand est est ce que ça ne
serait pas la fin du grand thèse c'est
que le constat c'est qu'il y a toujours
un malaise en alsace sur ce sujet
personne ne contestera
maintenant il faut qu'on réfléchisse
réfléchissent ensemble sur les
différents scénarios qu'on peut
envisager des scénarios raisonnable des
scénario rêvé
simplement je sais bien le fait de
fusionner les deux départements du
haut-rhin du bas-rhin
sans projet sans compétences
supplémentaires ça n'a strictement aucun
intérêt donc on se place pas directement
dans ce processus
si il faut des fonds supplémentaires
alors il faut des moyens supplémentaires
si on gère la misère à deux ça date à
part ça n'a rien ôté à la misère il faut
des eaux si vous travaillez sur un
projet commun s'appuie également sur les
intercommunalités pour réfléchir tous
ensemble de la façon dont nous voulons
fonctionner au cours des prochains mois
je crois qu'il faut surtout éviter qu'il
y ait des dissensions au sein notamment
des élus de la majorité
nous avons des élections présidentielles
puis législatives et aux élections
législatives
il faut pas donner une mauvaise image de
la classe politique alsacienne
il faut qu on part tous sur une volonté
commune celle de faire gagner l'alsace
on en discutera ça va durer quelques
semaines quelques mois mais il faut
qu'on trouve tous ensemble une solution
de consensus et l'alsace est toujours
construite sur le consensus rsa contre
bénévolat vous aviez fait l'actualité
toutes les chaînes ne reprenait ce là ce
avait été retoquée on pouvait pas faire
du blé du rsa contre bénévolat
aujourd'hui quelle est votre réponse
alors on a repris une nouvelle
délibération et maintenant cette
opération se fait dans le cadre du
contrat d'engagement réciproque entre
les bénéficiaires du rsa et la
collectivité ça démarre progressivement
mais on a l'ambition que une grande
majorité le volontarisme
ce volontariat lorsqu'ils viennent nous
solliciter on va discuter avec eux est
ce qu ils ont du temps disponible pour
s'engager auprès d'une association pour
s'engager auprès d'une collectivité
alors ça n'a absolument rien de punitif
c'est simplement pour permettre à l'épée
aux personnes qui sont aujourd'hui en
situation de chômage de longue durée
les bénéficiaires du rsa souvent n'ont
pas travaillé depuis plusieurs années et
on a 40% qui n'ont pas travaillé depuis
plus de cinq ans donc l'idée c'est de
leur remettre pied dans la société et
personne n'a vocation à rester au rsa et
donc leur permettre de les enlever un
peu
wade d'avoir de nouveau une ligne sur un
cv et je crois que cette idée soit
certainement l'un des thèmes aussi lors
des prochaines élections présidentielles
eric straumann deux questions encore
fessenheim qu'espérez-vous pour 2010 est
13ème la centrale nucléaire jeu clair
c'est clair si moi évidemment le c est
ce que vous espérez que le vainqueur de
des présidentielles revienne sur la
décision d'arrêter fessenheim ou si
comme on l'a entendu une grande
entreprise type tesla qui fabrique des
voitures électriques
si elle venait s'installer à la place de
fessenheim ça serait une bonne solution
alors est ce que vous mettez le curseur
alors d'abord il faut bien séparer des
sla de fessenheim parce que vendre en
californie l'installation d'une usine du
futur à côté d'une centrale nucléaire
or je n'y croyais pas non c'est pas là
dedans là je crois à la présence de ces
cela en alsace mais pas forcément
exactement sur le site de fessenheim
donc on a suffisamment de zones
économiques dans le haut rhin j'en ai du
côté de a été reine et les deux les deux
ne sont pas directement liées alors si
on décide des deux mains de la fermeture
de fessenheim
on va se retrouver avec deux mille
personnes sur les bras parce qu'il n'y a
strictement aucune proposition de
reconversion du site
c'est pour cette raison que je suis
aujourd'hui très dubitatif et le
président de la république ne va pas se
représenter et je crois que c'est
quelqu'un quand même qui a certes une
certaine conscience de l'intérêt
national de l'intérêt du grandes
entreprises nationales et qu'il ne
prendra pas de décision avant de quitter
la présidence de la république
on est tous d'accord fessenheim bas
fermé pas fermer un jour il faut
absolument s'y préparer mais le faire de
manière réfléchie dans le calme et que
ça s'inscrive dans la durée il faut
s'inscrire dans une dans un horizon de 5
10 ans voire 15 ans pour permettre la
reconversion du site et lardini à dreux
retrouver des emplois équivalents sur
cette zone